it's a millionaire theme our we're
interviewing actual real millionaires
people who have a net worth of over a
million dollars to find out how they did
it so you can learn how it really
happens in the real world not what
someone with a political agenda says and
not some what someone who has adopted a
victim mentality says because what we're
finding is the data from Tom Stanley's
book millionaire next door and then the
following book the millionaire mind
which I'm about halfway through the
millionaire mind again I hadn't read it
in a long long time you ought to get
that book and read it because it will
inspire you because you realize that you
are in control of your destiny you're in
control of your destiny that's the
that's the core of this Jeremy and
Victoria are with us in Denver Colorado
welcome guys
thank you David good to have you so
what's your all's net worth about 1.2
million about 1.2 very good and what's
that invested in part of that is a
retirement investments about four
hundred thousand there and then another
little over six hour thousand in real
estate
we own a rental property our primary
residence ok very cool very cool and how
old are you guys 36 and 33 wow you're
young millionaires excellent and what
has been your income through your
working life average average is about
150 but started out you know in that 50
60 thousand and when I started my
working career and I've been in sales
and every year have been able to
increase and increase and really
increase here the last couple years so
you're in sales and what does Victoria
do home with the kid full-time mom okay
yeah and so uh Jeremy what's your degree
in I have a marketing degree okay and
what was your GPA that somewhere around
3.5 okay all right and talk about that
what part debt has played positively or
negatively in this equation no the only
that we've ever had we both came into
our marriage debt-free with no
college loans we were alone going on we
had outside of our mortgage was a with a
car we bought one new car we first got
married and that was the only time paid
it off early and and and that was that
so we we've done our best to live by
your principles going through SVU early
on our marriage and then going through
it again here about about in three years
ago that's kind of where we got on this
path the wine to uh to get rid of the
remaining debt okay so that's when you
got the house paid off
yes we paid the rental off and then last
year we paid off our our primary and we
were lucky enough to get the calling and
give you our debt free straight I'll see
you down there that free screen very
cool so you've done by things now the
debt free scream in the millionaire hour
that's neat yes sir well there's
probably a correlation there that's
awesome so did you inherit money no no
we neither one of us did we're first
generation okay all right and what part
did giving play in your all's building
wealth it played a large part you know
our once you learn that early on that
this our money anyway like you talked
about it's a lot easier to give it away
and so we try to manage it the best that
we can some months our giving is equal
to or more than what we live on and when
we started our journey we committed to
increasing our giving as a percentage of
our budget each year and so God is just
continue to bless that Wow
so you start with the tithe and then you
go up from there huh yeah okay I love it
very cool what's the most expensive
jeans you buy Victoria Oh probably 50
$60 very cool that's good good how's it
feel
does it feel weird to be a millionaire
yeah a little bit I mean at 33 years old
you're a millionaire what we've been
very very blood yeah you have been
that's how it feels is blessed so talk
talk to people that are your age group
or are you know in their late 20s or
whatever what what do you what do you
attribute this to tell them the secrets
of the millionaire because they're not
secrets right but tell them what the
principles are
right IRA stinking what Jeremy said it
the sooner you realize that it's not
your money anyway just makes it so much
easier to manage it well and live within
your means you know no matter what you
make you have to live on less than what
you make and you know be able to save
and give and assuming you will figure
those you know a few key principles out
the sooner it can happen does it sound
weird when you when I say out loud that
if you keep on the track you're on with
no huge catastrophes or tragedies that
you're probably going to have 20 million
dollars when you're 70 yeah that's crazy
yeah that because that's where you're
headed you realize that mathematically
that's what should happen Wow and that's
with no huge you know that's without you
not you know maybe you don't make 500 a
year you just keep making about what
you're making you don't even you don't
double your income or anything and you
probably will do that actually the is my
guess but congratulations you guys
thanks for thanks for being a great
American success story
computer [ __ ] you talking about these
and giving us a chance to come out and
share we hope it's encouragement to
others
it absolutely is no question about that